[Music]
good evening at welcome to tucker
carlson tonight just a week to go from
tonight until the midterms an election
day is finally becoming a referendum on
something that really matters
immigration who gets to live here what
does citizenship mean what kind of
country do we want these are not small
incidental questions what you're
watching is not an argument about
Russian Facebook ads or stormy Daniels
or her creepy lawyer some other
diversion designed to prevent you from
thinking clearly these are core debates
these are the arguments that every
functioning democracy must have and yet
ours rarely does consider the question
of birthright citizenship under current
interpretations of American law anyone
born on our soil automatically becomes a
US citizen context is irrelevant it
doesn't matter if your parents were
tourists or illegal aliens or foreign
saboteurs if their plane was forced down
to refuel and you emerged it doesn't
matter if you were born on our property
you are a citizen well in a recent
interview with Axios President Trump
suggested this is not a great deal for
America he pledged to change it with an
executive order as of tonight it seems
likely that order would abolish
so-called birth tourism that's where
people travel to the United States
solely for the purpose of having kids
and witting citizenship along with the
many benefits that follow from that well
know more about it soon and of course
will tell you when we do know but nobody
else in Washington is waiting for
details they hate it already the very
same people who have spent decades
trying to gut the bill of rights are now
lecturing the rest of us that the idea
is brace yourself unconstitutional Paul
Ryan for example he's the outgoing
Speaker of the House he announced his
opposition to this immediately
the very idea he said is ridiculous
listen well you obviously cannot do that
you cannot end birthright citizenship
with an executive order note the
phrasing obviously that's what people
say when they don't feel like making a
rational case for their positions
usually because they can't
is it really quote obvious that the
Constitution requires us to give
citizens
to the children of illegal aliens Paul
Ryan has no idea he just doesn't want to
have a conversation about it he wants
you to be quiet in fact as a legal
matter it is an open question the
Supreme Court has never ruled on it but
there was ample reason to believe the
law does not apply to illegal immigrants
or birth tourists birthright citizenship
arises from the Fourteenth Amendment
that was passed just three years after
the Civil War and it was passed to
guarantee T citizenship to freed slaves
the senator who wrote the citizenship
clause in the Fourteenth Amendment Jacob
Howard of Michigan explained the point
of it on the Senate floor at the time
quote the amendment will not of course
include persons born in the United
States who were foreigners aliens who
belonged to the families of ambassadors
or foreign ministers and quote again the
amendment was designed to ensure that
newly freed slaves would be treated as
the American citizens they were the
point was to enfranchise African
Americans the point was not to enable
the rest of the world to scam our system
to abuse our generosity Trump's proposal
would get us closer to the purpose of
the Fourteenth Amendment and for that he
is being denounced naturally as a racist
listen to some of the dumb people on TV
what used to be five years ago ten years
ago dog whistles to appeal to the fears
of white voters now our just stated
openly the principle principle debate in
Europe in the United States the real
fault line that gets people going is
this issue of openness how open are we
to people how open are we to trade and
it's this issue of national identity
versus aunt internationalism globalism
if you will so what Donald Trump is
doing is he is mining that fault line he
is he is working it whether it's
birthright citizenship whether it's
sending troops to a border that's not
under siege we're no longer arguing
serious issues about how to regulate our
economies we're not no longer arguing
serious issues say about how to fight
the cold war we are arguing questions
about national identity and it's not
that far to get from that to issues of
racism so let's get this straight
defining citizenship is not quote a
serious issue
only in New York and Washington we're
serious is where to find good burrata or
how to get to the Hamptons in under
three hours on a Friday night
these people are total buffoons in fact
there is no more serious debate than the
debate over citizenship and it's long
overdue
globally birthright citizenship is the
rare exception it is not the rule Canada
and the US are the only developed
countries that have birthright
citizenship not a single European
country allows it out of the 54
countries in Africa only to offer
birthright citizenship are the other 52
racist how about Harry Reid is he a
racist to watch the former Democratic
Senate majority leader
explain his views on birthright
citizenship if making it easy to be an
illegal alien is enough how about
offering a reward for being an illegal
immigrant no Sun no sane country would
do that right
guess again if you break our laws by
entering this country without permission
and give birth to a child we reward that
child with US citizenship and guarantee
of full access to all public and social
services this society provides and
that's a lot of services is it any
wonder that two-thirds of the babies
born at taxpayer expensive country
county run hospitals in Los Angeles are
born to illegal alien mothers now as a
factual matter that's tougher than
anything Donald Trump has ever said keep
in mind that just four years ago that
man Harry Reid was the top Democrat in
the Senate try saying that today he'd be
called Bull Connor and shouted off the
stage but the questions he raised are
still fair questions is unlimited
birthright citizenship helping this
country or is it hurting this country
under our current system illegal
immigrants who come to the US and have
children are eligible to receive tax
credits food stamps other welfare
benefits those are huge incentives not
surprisingly one in every 12 births in
this country right now is to someone
here illegally and that total does not
even include birth birth tourism every
year tens of thousands of foreign
nationals come to this country on
tourist visas solely to give birth to
the Chinese are strongly
over-represented in this when ad in
China offers quote high-end us birth
tourism specialists end quote for just
20 grand these experts navigate clients
through the process of having a child in
America in return for that 20 grand
their kids gain the right to Social
Security Medicare countless other
federal programs if they come back to
the US for college they get in-state
tuition federally backed student loans
financial aid all the benefits that
ought to be going to actual Americans
who are drowning in college debt this is
a scam there is no other word for it and
by the way don't blame the Chinese or
the Russians or the Salvadorans or
anybody else using the system we're the
ones offering it why wouldn't they take
it the blame lies with us no other
country would allow itself to be
relentlessly exploited like this for
decades and no other leadership class
would side with foreigners over its own
people and yet ours does every time and
that tells you everything